[Music]
gavin welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are y'all doing doing great how
can we help
hey so um
i'm going to try to put it into words
and but it's going to make more sense as
we go along here but my big question as
of right now is uh i'm a young guy and
i've i've saved a pretty good amount of
money here and i'm looking to figure out
uh what is the
fastest and safest
way to go ahead uh and build this wealth
here and
you know i know we're gonna get into the
uh the baby steps here but uh you know i
i do have some questions about them in
regards to achieving this goal okay how
young are you i'm 24 years old what's
your household income
uh right now i make about 80 000 a year
okay and how much wealth have you
amassed
so far um i have about
40 to 42 000 in uh just apple stock i
have another 2 000 uh another individual
stock
about 11 000 in my roth ira
and about 3 000 sitting in the bank so i
think that's roughly about 60.
okay and you don't have any consumer
debt
no sir i have no debt at all and you've
got a fully funded emergency fund it
sounds like you have 3 000 savings
uh i have a like a small one i have like
the thousand dollar emergency fund but
not like i wouldn't say i haven't
established three to six months one just
yet
is there a reason why you skipped over
that one or
um
to be honest i kind of uh i became a fan
of y'all just fairly recently so that's
kind of why that worked out that way i'm
actually like that's my next step right
now is to go ahead and build that three
to six month fund i'm currently
using my gi bill i'm a veteran
and i'm going to school for computer
science right now very cool thank you
for your service yeah well gavin you've
done an incredible job i mean you're
you're making 80k you have
you have you know
a great nest egg here i mean you and as
young as you are no debt i mean like you
really are um
i can tell you're motivated and so i
love
your question i would say on a tactical
level
um i would use some of this stock that
you have just to cash out some of it
just to go ahead and just get an
emergency fund today i mean you could
just go ahead and put some of that in a
money market account along with that 3k
you have 1 thousand dollars and you have
3 000 bank i mean you can combine a
little bit of this take some of that
stock out um
but i'll say this gavin after
you know we've been doing this ramsey
solutions for over three decades helping
people build wealth and you are
well on your way for sure to do that
um but i think a couple of things get in
the way of that and that can can kind of
um train wreck this for some people
number one is is greed and number two is
impatience
and those sometimes go hand in hand and
so my encouragement to you would be that
what we have found on our everyday
millionaires doing this stuff
is that
being wealthy and or getting wealthy
right building um
building a huge nest egg
it takes a little bit of time and it's
more like a marathon it's not a sprint
and it's not going to be
super cool it's not going to be these
little secrets and these well you do
this and put your money here and you're
going to turn and get this investment
they're going to remain
all the stuff it's actually really
boring gavin like like the way we teach
it because
the way we do that is because there's a
proven process and you want to have a
long track record on something to say
hey
this is what we do so what we have found
is people are building their wealth by
just traditional investing so you're
doing your roth ira which is awesome if
your company doesn't match your 401k but
doing these traditional retirement
routes is awesome and then going in and
saying hey okay let's look at just a
good growth stock mutual funds let's
look at some other things so instead of
having these single stocks that carry
more risk because it's one thing even
though i know it's apple right and you
could say walmart but
but there is a level where you're saying
okay i am i'm putting a lot of my eggs
in one basket versus diversifying like a
good mutual fund would have 90 to 200
stocks apple could be included in that
but but 90 to 200 companies and so
that's it's a more conservative approach
but it's one that is going to be able to
take lower that risk now we do say when
you're once you're on baby step seven
which means you have no mortgage you
have no payments
then you can take about 10 of your of
your net worth and kind of just have a
little bit of fun with that so whatev
whatever that looks like for you maybe
that's yeah buying a single stock here
or there it's not something that i we
advise though
on on the front end by any means so
um the wealth building that we teach
it's not super glamorous not the sexiest
but it but it but it works is what i'm
saying it works my husband this is what
we've done we've done this for 12 years
we're in baby step 7 and we we throw as
much money we max out everything every
year 401k roth iras we have another
mutual fund we put we have
a vanguard account we have stuff spread
around but when we just we just we save
money and then the other turned to gavin
i'll just add it and then george i'm
sorry you can jump in but it is the
generous piece too gavin i want you to
be giving at this point too because
there is something to be said that
yes building wealth is fun buying stuff
is fun going on vacations is fun all of
it
but nothing nothing changes you like
writing a check for a ten thousand
dollar car and buying someone who needs
a car car just because you can i mean
there's there's things like that that i
want you to
to weave into your story and your money
plan as well yeah gavin do you own a
house yeah
um so no currently um i'm currently i'm
living with family and my big thing is
that because i'm still in school you
know and i'm i'm having kind of a set
target day here to graduate
my theory was was that because i'm in
san antonio it's not exactly the big
technology hub oh yeah um i i figured i
wanted to be open here's why
i want you to have a paid for house uh
before you jump into some fun times
investing so that would be my next goal
from you that's gonna be your fastest
path to wealth is not having a payment
whether it's rent or mortgage so that'd
be my next goal man but you're doing
great but just do things in the right
order to set yourself up for success
this is the ramsay show